we've had a lot of people reach out to
specifically from Canada that are
working professionals like doctors
who've had former patients sending
complaints to colleges to get their
licenses and they're like oh I don't
like what you're saying on Twitter what
profession does that mean you can't
exactly trust to tell you the truth
anymore Well you certainly can't trust
Physicians or psychologists because
they're mandated with regard to
affirmative care now you can't assume
that if you take a child of yours whose
gender dysphoric in for professional
evaluation that they're going to get any
evaluation at all because psychologists
and Physicians are mandated to do
nothing but agree with the gender
dysphoric individual and lawyers are in
the same situation as well at the legal
profession in Ontario mandated diversity
equity and inclusivity requirements in
relationship to hiring with the clear
implication that if you didn't buy the
Dei social justice Warrior political
line that your Law Firm was no longer in
concordance with the dictates of the
professional governing body